hello welcome to the section on
probabilistic
classification
so so far we've talked about classifiers
that given a record
you return for us a prediction
of which class the target variable lies
in
and now we want to talk in this section
about an extension of that idea instead
of having a classifier that simply
predicts one value we want to think
about a classifier that can
make more general types of predictions
so if we have a classifier that predicts
one value we'll say call it v-hat
that would be called a point classifier
or a point predictor
it makes just one guess
a classifier that produces more than a
single guess
might for example produce a list of
guesses
or an ordered list of guesses
so it says here are the top three things
so for example we've got a camera it's
sitting on a car it's looking at all the
things out on the street
and it says well you know that could be
a pedestrian or it could
be a person riding a scooter or it could
be
a person
who is riding a bicycle and
um those should be the the best guesses
that the predictor makes it knows it's
not a car
but it can't determine exactly which one
of those three things it is
and it may rank those guesses
this is most likely to be a uh
pedestrian second choice of scooter
third choice
bicyclist um
another possible output
of a predictor or a classifier would be
a probability distribution
on possible targets
so with probability 0.9 it's a
pedestrian with probability of 0.05
somebody on a scooter
with probably 0.05 it's
somebody on a bicycle
and these are very common
in fact probabilistic classification is
probably the most
common type of classifier that people
use
today um
we also are of course quite familiar
with the idea of probabilistic
predictions from weather forecasts
if you look at your weather app on your
phone
it will tell you the chance of rain
today is 10
for example
so let's just consider a list classifier
um so this is a classifier that produces
an
ordered list we might call these v
top v second and v third as its
best first second and third best
uh guesses for what the true
y should be what the true v should be
and of course it may produce three
guesses it may produce a top ten
or it could be a variable number
sometimes it will know
with with this very strong certainty
that it's a
pedestrian and others it may have more
uncertainty and so it produces two
or three or ten guesses
and so some predictors do produce a
variable number of guesses and some
predictors
always produce a fixed number
um and so if we're trying to
uh uh evaluate such a
predictor well you know we'd be
obviously happiest if the true v
is the first choice of the predictor
and a little bit less happy if it's the
second choice and so on
um one place you very often see
a list predictions and a recommendation
system
so amazon has a
predictor for example that looks at
your recent browsing history and looks
at your recent purchases
and tries to figure out what you're most
likely to be interested in
for your next purchase and show you
those things
and so it will figure out your top 10
list of things you're most likely to buy
or most likely be interested in and show
you those
uh one way to to make a list classifier
is to use
unembedding that we've seen so far
so for example we've used nearest
neighbor
unembedding to construct a classifier
we have a prediction algorithm that
produces a y-hat we have a bunch of
different representatives embedded in rm
psi 1 through side k and
our predictor so far has always just
returned for us
the representative which is closest
to y hat but it could equally well
return for us the three
closest representatives to y hat and
those would be the
three um our best predictions and the
closest one would be the top guess the
second closest one would be the second
guess and so on
so we're going to spend some time in the
next
few sections talking about probabilistic
methods and so we really need to start
looking at probability in earnest so
this is where the co-requisite in this
class
of knowing about probability is going to
start to come into play
we're not going to use a great deal of
probability but we will
certainly use sum and so uh just
a brief review right here of probability
our probability distribution on our
target set
b it's it's a function uh for each
element
of our target set it gives us a real
number
and those real numbers have to be
non-negative and add up to one
and those are the probabilities
associated
with those elements of the target set b
so p of v is the probability
of the value v
um so for example if the target set is
rain and shine
we might have p of rain is 0.15 and p
of shine is 0.85 if our predictor
is predicting a probability that it will
rain of 15
and the probability that it will not
rain over 85 percent
um if we have a probability distribution
like this
well we have numbered the entries
in the target set v as v1
through v capital k okay categories or k
classes well then we've
also got uh
pvi which is the probability of vi we
can think about
as the ice entry in a probability
distribution
vector and so our probability
assigns a number to each of those k
classes
and so we've actually got k numbers
which form give us a k dimensional
vector
and so in vector notation we might say
that p is greater than or equal to zero
and what that means is that that
inequality should be interpreted
element wise all of the entries p sub i
of p as a vector are non-negative
and the fact that the because this is a
probability distribution
the entries have to sum up to one we can
express that as one transpose p is equal
to one
where the one on the left there
is the vector of all ones and so that's
simply saying that the entries have to
sum up to one
so we can either think about our
probability distributions as
functions which mapped script v to the
reals
or we can think about them as k
dimensional vectors
both of those are convenient
and we will make use of both choices of
notation
a probabilistic classifier produces a
probability distribution
p hat on v given u
so we have a classifier it takes in the
input u
and it returns for us a prediction and
instead of that prediction
being y hat um
an embedded value of
uh v or instead of it being v hat a
prediction
of which class
the target variable lies in it produces
as p
hat and so the hat here indicates
prediction
and p hat is a probability distribution
on
v so it's a number associated with each
of the different classes which
think which informs us
how likely the classifier thinks
each one of the different classes is
to correspond to that particular u
so we'll write this as p hat is g of u
this is capital g so the capital
g is used in the same way we used it
before
in that we use little g's to indicate
a predictor that's taking input x
and producing an output y and a big g
to use to indicate a predictor that's
that's unembedded that's composed with
the embedding and unembedding operations
to take in an input u and produce
an output v and here
because we're dealing with probabilistic
classification
we're using capital g to indicate a
predictor
that takes in an input u and returns for
us
an output which is a probability
distribution
on v so
when you read this you should keep in
mind
that we've got something a little tricky
going on here
g is a function and it's returning a
distribution which is itself a function
so we want a function that returns a
function
we can call the function so
we get p hat as g of u and then i can
take p hat and evaluate
it at a particular class v i so i can
take p
hat of v i and that would give us the
probability that v
is v i when the independent variable is
u
of course i could just write that all at
once i could say
g of u evaluated at v i which i'd write
as g
parenthesis u parentheses v i
um and so here um
of course this is totally fine we used
functions returning concrete objects
such as numbers and vectors and matrices
and here we've got a function
that's returning a more abstract object
which is a function
and modern programming languages such as
julia can happily do this
we've seen this already when we pass
around loss functions
in julia and so here we're going to pass
around probability distributions which
are just functions
now in some sense the point classifier
and probability class probabilistic
classifiers
are related to each other um we can say
well for example a point classifier is a
special case of a probabilistic
classifier it's a probabilistic
classifier
that's saying the probability of a
particular target is a hundred percent
and the probability of all the other
classes is
zero so we could construct such a thing
we'd have p
hat of v being one if v is v hat
and zero otherwise
and that would be a distribution that
corresponds to a hundred percent
certainty that the guess is v hat and
zero percent certainty
for the others zero percent probability
of the others
um and typically this is not what you
want of course yes it's a probabilistic
classifier you've taken a point
classifier and constructed a
probabilistic classifier
but you haven't gained any more
information out of this
you can also go the other way you can if
you've got a probabilistic classifier
you can construct a point classifier so
what you do is you say well my
probabilistic classifier gave me a
probability distribution p hat
let me look uh out of all of the v's
for the one that's most likely the one
which maximizes
p hat of v and uh
that would be a way of translating
a probabilistic prediction into a
deterministic prediction into a very
specific prediction which is actionable
um so for example if you
uh
have a predictor of the weather that's
telling you the probability of rain
at some point you have to make that
actionable you have to decide am i going
to carry an umbrella outside or not
and so one way to do that would be to
say is it more likely that it's going to
rain
or that it's going to shine that it's
not going gonna rain
and if it's more likely it's gonna rain
then you carry your umbrella
if it's more likely that it's gonna be
sunny then you don't carry your umbrella
and of course there are many ways of
translating probability probability
distributions into actions
and this is just one way of doing it
this particular method of translating
a probabilistic prediction into a point
prediction
is called maximum likelihood
we look for the
class that's most likely that has
highest probability we can also
generate a list classifier from a
probabilistic classifier
simply by giving the value sorted by
probability
there are several different ways of
constructing a probabilistic classifier
um all of the ones that we've seen so
far for
point classifiers can be extended so one
can have a tree braced
tree-based probabilistic classifier
which is a decision tree
has nodes labeled by feature and
threshold value
and the leaves contain distributions
rather than
point predictions you can have a nearest
neighbor probabilistic classifier
now the way that works is then if you
have a
predicted if you have a query point x
then you look for the k nearest
neighbors 2x so the x sub i's
in your data set which are the closest
to x
and then amongst those you look at the
distribution
of vi's that you have so if three of
them
are true and five of them are false then
one would predict a probability of
three-fifths
for the corresponding target variable at
the point x
you can also do probabilistic
classifiers which are based on linear
predictors or based on neural network
predictors and we will come to those
shortly
so here we have a nearest neighbor
classifier
we've embedded the use
in r2 to give us two dimensional x's
given a query point
we would look at the corresponding point
in the plane
and we would like to predict either red
or blue
for the corresponding class
now the way we do it is here we look at
the k nearest neighbors
of our query point so here k has been
chosen to be eight
so for any given query point we look at
the eight nearest neighbors let's look
at an example
so we'll have a query point
say right here and
we'll draw a circle that contains eight
neighbors
which i would guess is
something like that and then of those
eight neighbors we will count how many
of them are red and how many of them are
blue
and that will give us the prediction
probability
distribution the empirical distribution
that we're seeing
amongst the nearest eight neighbors and
so here the colors
in this plot are chosen accordingly
so if the prediction is
uh blue 100 red zero percent then that's
this color which is dark blue
if the prediction is red hundred percent
blue zero percent that's this orange
color
and of course the colors in between
vary and really we're only predicting
one probability here because once we've
got a prediction probability
for a blue the prediction probability
for red is one minus the probability for
blue
so now we want to consider well suppose
we've got
a probabilistic classifier or a list
classifier how are we going to evaluate
how good they are
um and there are several different ways
of doing this
it's not quite as simple as it is for a
point classifier if we're trying to
judge a list classifier
then we may look at the
error rate as a function of the list
rank so for example we look we have a
test data say
set we have a true value of v and we
have our predictor
is given us is giving us
uh v top the second and v
third as our as its guesses
and then we ask ourselves well you know
how many
of our of the how many points in the
test set
did the predictor
get v top to be the actual true v
and we might find that say 68 of the
samples
the v top was actually the true v
and then we could say well how many of
the test set points was the true value
among the top two guesses and that might
be has to be higher than 68
that might be 79 and amongst the top
three guesses might be 85
and so if you want just one number you
might decide well i'm really concerned
that it'd be in the top three
as long as it's in the top three i'm
happy and uh
in which case 85 percent might be a
reasonable
accuracy another way
to do it might be to score
the test data set so for every
data point vi in the test data set
we look at whether it was the
top guess in which case we could be
three points
the second best guess in which it gets
two points or the third best guess in
which case
it gets one point and then we add the
scores over the entire
test set and that's a measure of how
good a job
our list classifier did
now to judge a probabilistic classifier
that's a
reasonably subtle idea
what do we have well we have
a data set with using v's in it and then
for each one of those data
points we have a prediction
p hat and so
[Music]
um so for each data point
uh we have a true value the v
and we have a prediction which is a
probability distribution
p hat over the set of possible v's
and one way to say whether this is a
good prediction or not would be to say
let's look at the p hat that we got and
see
whether it gives a high probability
to the actual value that happened v
so for example if we've got a prediction
of rain and
um we look back at historical data
and we look at the predictions of rain
based on the weather the day before
and we look on whether it did rain or
not well what we'd like to see
is that on days when it rained the
probability
predicted for rain was large and on days
when it didn't rain
we'd like the probability predicted for
rain to be small
and if we see something like that we
might say well that's a good
predictor
now we've got to meet this idea formal
um
the the most common way of formalizing
this idea
is to use what's called a log likelihood
so we have a data set u1 through un v1
through vn
and we're going to have
a prediction at each of those uis
which will call p hat i it's the output
of our predictor when we feed
ui in and it's a probability
distribution
over the v's now
if this were the
true distribution of so if p hat i
was the true probability distribution
that the v
i's that v i was generated according to
then we could ask ourselves what is the
probability
of seeing that sequence v1 through vn
so if i is 1 the probability of getting
the particular
v that we got is given by evaluating
p hat one at that particular v which is
just v one
similarly for v for i is equal to two we
have to evaluate
p hat two at v two
and those give us the probabilities of
getting those outcomes
under that distribution if we make the
probabilistic assumption
that each of those data points
is independent then the
probability of getting the entire data
set is the product of the individual
probabilities
and so the probability of seeing that
entire data set
under those distributions p hat 1
through p hat
n is simply the product from i is one to
n of p
hat i evaluated at v i
so this is just a probability it says
when you've got some distribution and
what's the probability of getting that
particular outcome
and we can look at it as well just the
probability of getting the outcome
but we can also look at it another way
and look at it as
a measure of the distributions p
hat 1 through p hat n and
when we do that instead of calling it
the probability of getting
v's we call it the likelihood of p
hats being correct
so the likelihood is simply another name
for the probability
but we call it the probability when
we're looking at the probability of
outcomes
and we call it the likelihood when we're
talking about the likelihood
of probability distributions
and so we'd like this quantity the
probability or the likelihood
to be large
and this is a fundamental measure of how
well the predicted distribution matches
the data
just as in our main versus sun example
if the probability of rain is large on
days when it did rain
that's a good predictor
so we can compare two different
classifiers by looking at their
associated likelihoods which one has the
largest probability value their largest
likelihood
the one with the largest likelihood we
would consider the better
classifier
now it's actually more convenient to
work with log
probabilities rather than purely
probabilities now one reason for that is
that the likelihood is the product and
when we take the log we're going to get
a sum
uh there are some other reasons for that
as well which we'll see
um so what we work with is actually the
negative log
likelihood that's simply the negative
log of the probability
of getting v 1 through v n under our
predicted distributions p hat 1 through
p hat n
that's the negative log of the product
of the p hat is evaluated to the v i's
which is negative of the sum of the logs
of the pi's of the eyes
now the negative log likelihood is
actually a positive quantity
and we would like it to be small if the
negative log is small that means the
property
probability itself is large
one of the things about this is that
this is
if we just look at the log of the
probabilities then
that gets smaller the more data points
we have
and so we need to normalize in some way
and the way we do that
is we look at the average negative log
likelihood
so that's here l minus 1 on n
the sum from i is 1 to n of the log of p
hat i of v i and this is a quantity that
we can compare
the effectiveness of
different classifiers on different size
data sets
so now we have a a very nice
performance metric which is this
average negative log likelihood
now just as we did when we were looking
at loss functions when we're looking at
the square loss and the absolute loss
we asked ourselves the question if we
just looked at constant classifiers
which would be the best constant
classifier
which minimizes the average value of
those losses
here we have a particular performance
metric the average negative log
likelihood
we can ask ourselves the question which
is
the best constant
predictor the best constant
probabilistic classifier
that minimizes
that particular performance metric
um so how is this going to work well
we're going to
have a data set which is just
v1 through vn a bunch of classes
and we're going to look for a classifier
that doesn't depend on the use
so the user don't even exist all we're
going to do is try to predict
a distribution p hat
um and that distribution p hat has to be
a probability distribution
on script v
so what do we do we're going to choose
script we're going to choose
p hat to minimize the average negative
log likelihood
minus 1 on n the sum from i is 1 to n of
the log
of p hat of v i and we can choose any
distribution p hat we want of course it
has to be a probability distribution
so it has to be non-negative at every
point v
and it has to sum to 1.
now it turns out
that the optimal constant probabilistic
classifier is very nice it's a very
sensible
quantity it's actually the empirical
distribution
of the data so the empirical
distribution of the data
we simply count up for each v
in script v the fraction of the data
which are equal to that particular class
so it's simply the empirical
distribution it's simply the the counts
divided by the total number
of data elements we have we'll call that
q
and then the p hat that minimizes the
average negative log likelihood
is q
and this is this is very nice this is
simp this is just like when we talked
about
minimizing the square loss we found that
the best constant predictor was the mean
when we talked about minimizing the
absolute loss
we found the best constant predictor is
the median now we're predicting
probabilities
and when we think about minimizing the
average negative log likelihood the best
constant predictor
is the empirical distribution
now the negative log
likelihood can be computed in a
particular way
so we have the negative log likelihood
is minus 1 on n the sum from i is 1 to n
of the log of p hat v i
now each of the v i's lives in one of
the classes
now remember what the classes are we use
this notation
v is v 1
up to v k notice those are subscripts
to indicate the classes we've got the
data elements which are
v superscript i from i to 1 up to n
now if i compute this quantity the sum
from i is one
up to n of the log
of p hat of v i
well i can split that sum up i can split
it up
into those eyes
for which v i is say v one
and then i can take the log of p hat
of v i but all of those v i's are v one
so i can just write that v
one and then i can do the next category
such that vi is v2
of the log of p-hat of v2
and so on up to k categories
sum from our over i such that v i
is v k of the log
of p hat of v k
so by splitting it up like this i just
split it up into
into uh categories
notice that this in inside here
inside each of these sums the
the terms don't depend on i
so i've really got just a certain number
of terms that are all the same
and the number that i've got well it
just the
it's just the number of data points for
which vi
is v1 in this sum the number of data
points which vi is v2
in this sum and so on
so when i work out this sum and taking
into account the factor of
n well then the fraction of
terms is q
v j those are the those are that's the
fraction
of the terms in this sum for which v i
is equal to category v j and
for those each one of those terms the
quantity log p hat of v i is just log p
hat of the corresponding class v j
so i end up with the sum over the
categories rather than the sum over the
data points
and i have that the average negative
negative log likelihood is the sum over
the categories
of the empirical
distribution of each of the categories
times the log of the probability of that
category
this quantity is called the cross
entropy of p hat relative to q
where p hat is the
distribution that is
being evaluated it's the distribution
that's produced by the predictor
and q is the underlying
true empirical distribution
of the v's we might write this
as uh h oops
h of q
p hat is equal to minus the sum
from j is one up to k
of q j log
p hat j using our vector
notation
there's also a related quantity when p
hat and q are the same distribution
so we'll call them both p that's
quantity
is called h of p that's the
sum over k of p
k log p k negative
p k log p k that's called the entropy
of a probability distribution and both
of these quantities the cross entropy
and the entropy
are very important
mathematically very important
practically
they're used very widely
in coding theory and in information
theory
and in machine learning they're
fundamental
properties of probability distributions
we don't need much of the theory of that
here or in fact any of the theory of it
here
we just want to be able to determine
which is the p hat that minimizes the
average negative
log likelihood another way to say it is
if i've got a q which p hat minimizes
h of q p hat because h of q p hat the
cross entropy
is the average negative log likelihood
there's a convenient quantity
to use for this and that's called the
callback libra divergence of q and p
so we've got h of q p we'd like to
minimize that
over p but actually instead of looking
at h of q
p we're going to look at this thing
called the callback libelo divergence
dkl of qp
and that's h of qp minus h of q
minus the entropy of q
this is convenient for the following
reason
we want to minimize h of q p
over p
but actually well h of
q p is just d
k l of q p
plus h of q
if i'm minimizing this quantity over p
well this additional term here doesn't
matter because it doesn't depend on p
just depends on q it's just a constant
so we're just
shifting the objective function in our
optimization problem
um this quantity the callback libra
divergence
uh has a very nice property that it's
non-negative one way to think about it
is that it's a measure of how
similar to distributions probability
distributions p and q are and when
they are the same well then
dqp is zero
because if we look back in our
definition
of entropy
h of p is
the cross entropy of p with itself
and so
when q is equal to p we clearly have
that the
callback libelou divergence of q and p
is zero
and when q and p are not equal well then
the callback
divergence is always non-negative
all right this is uh easy to see
if i just look at what the sum is dkl of
qp
is the sum over j of qj log
pj on qj so here we're using our vector
notation pj is simply a shorthand
for p of v j
um so here i've used the fact that i've
subtracted
one log from another and that's simply
the
log of the ratio um
now the log of pj over qj
uh has a nice bound now the log
of a quantity log this is one
and then the logarithm
looks like that and i can compare that
with the function x minus 1
function x minus 1 is the tangent right
there
and so the log of x is less than or
equal to x minus 1.
this implies that this sum
is less than or equal to is greater than
or equal to this sum
and this sum we can expand as being
equal to
the sum over j of
p j minus the sum
over j of q j and both of those terms
are equal to one and so because both p
and q are distributions and so the
overall sum
adds up to zero hence the
callback light blur divergence of p
in q is greater than or equal to zero
here we used uh the fact that q was
non-zero
when we did this division um
uh but uh in fact this proof can be
shown to hold
even if some of the qs are equal to zero
and that tells us the best constant
predictor
the best constant predictor is the given
by the
p hat that minimizes the average
negative log likelihood the average
negative long likelihood
is equal to the cross entropy
and so we would like to minimize h
of q p hat with respect to p hat
we can make this term
zero by setting p hat equal to q and
of course this is just a constant term
and so
when p hat is q um that's the best
constant predictor
best constant predictor as a
probability distribution equal to the
empirical distribution
the resulting uh cross entropy
is the entropy of q
so let's summarize uh a point classifier
makes a single guess of the given u
whereas a probabilistic classifier
guesses a probability distribution on
the target set
on the target set of classes v given the
u
and we judge a probabilistic classifier
by its average
log likelihood on test data
you